S
ON THE CREW.
>> THE HEAD OF THE NATION'S
SECOND-LARGEST TEACHERS UNION
FIRING BACK AT CRITICS.
BLASTING THE ROLE OF SCHOOL
CLOSURES AND THE EDUCATIONAL
PROGRESS OF SCHOOLCHILDREN.
BLAMING THE PREVIOUS A
ADMINISTRATION, NO TEACHER I
KNOW ENJOYS IT WITH PRIVATE
LEARNING.
TWENTY IN A CLASSROOM, 20 AT
HOME, FORMER PRESIDENT DONALD
TRUMP RANTED AND RAVED AS THEY
PUT THE SAFETY MEASURES IN PLACE
TO GET THIS DONE.
THE FORMER EDUCATION SECRETARY
IS NOT TAKING THE ATTACK
LIGHTLY.
>> RANDY SHOULD OWN UP TO THE
MISTAKES THAT THEY MADE IN THE
WAY THAT THEY HAVE HARMED KIDS
AND HARM FAMILIES ACROSS THE
COUNTRY, YET ALL SHE IS DOING IS
BLAMING EVERYBODY ELSE.
THIS IS NOT ABOUT TEACHERS, THIS
IS ABOUT SHE AND ALL OF HER
ALLIES THAT CONTINUE TO CONTROL
EVERYTHING WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY 99% OF CONTRIBUTIONS GOING
DIRECTLY TO DEMOCRATS DO THEIR
BIDDING.
THEY HAVE ESPECIALLY FAILED THE
KIDS AND THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE
OBSERVANT TO.
>> ONLY 42% SAY THAT THEY ARE
COMPLETELY OR SOMEWHAT SATISFIED
AND THAT IS DOWN NEARLY 10
POINTS SINCE JUST 2019.
AND THEN WE HAVE MORE FROM THE
UNION AND THE CDC.
>> SO WHAT DOES IT TELL US?
WELL, IT TELLS US THAT THE
UNIONS WANTED THE SCHOOLS
CLOSED.
AND WE DON'T HAVE TO JUST LOOK
AT THAT, WE CAN LOOK AT THE
CONCEPT THAT INCLUDES WE ARE ALL
FOR OPENING UP AND SO I ASKED
SOMEONE TO LOOK UP THE LAWSUITS
IN THIS COUNTRY WHERE THEY WERE
TRYING TO OPEN UP, AND THEY SAID
THERE WERE SOME LAWSUITS SAYING
SOME LAWSUITS WANT THE SCHOOLS
CLOSED.
AND I SAID, WELL, LET ME THINK.
I WONDER WHO IS PUSHING, WHO IS
SUING.
THE TEACHERS UNIONS.
SO THERE IS NO QUESTION ABOUT
IT.
THEY CAN REWRITE HISTORY ALL
THEY WANT, BUT THE TRUTH IS THAT
OUR KIDS HAVE SUFFERED
TREMENDOUSLY AND THEY HAVE HAD
THE MONEY TO GET THE SCHOOLS
READY IN THE SCHOOLS ARE NOT
READY AND KIDS ARE GOING TO LOSE
GOING FORWARD ON A GLOBAL SCALE
AND AFTER THE FIRST FEW MONTHS
OF COVID-19, THIS IS TOO SERIOUS
OF AN ISSUE TO BLAME THE OTHER
GUY.
>> AND ALSO TO YOUR POINT ABOUT
THE MONEY, 87% OF THE
$122 QUINTILLION, AMERICAN
TAXPAYERS WERE GENEROUS, WE NEED
THESE RESOURCES 2 IT'S LIKE THE
FIRST TIME THAT THE GOVERNMENT
HASN'T BEEN LIKE A, SOMETHING IS
UP.
[LAUGHTER]
IT'S MY MEMORY.
>> 15 DAYS, SLOWING THE SPREAD
IN APRIL, ALL THE SCHOOLS ARE
OUT UNTIL THE SUMMER BREAK.
RED STATES, BLUE STATES, THAT'S
HOW IT WENT DOWN, THE PRESIDENT
SAID THAT WE NEEDED TO START
REOPENING SCHOOLS AND HE WAS
KILLED IN THE PRESS.
THE DEMOCRATS SAID IT'S
DANGEROUS, YOU ARE GOING TO KILL
THE CHILDREN.
AND IN THE FALL, MOSTLY RED
STATES OPENED UP, ALMOST ALL,
AND I REMEMBER THAT DE SANTIS
GOT HAMMERED FOR THAT.
A LOT OF THE BIGGEST STATE COOL
DISTRICTS, THEY WERE ALL REMOTE
AND HE GOT HIT FOR I THINK THE
SACRAMENTO SCHOOL DISTRICT AND
HE WAS SENDING HIS KIDS TO
PRIVATE SCHOOL IN CLASS AND THEN
JOE BIDEN GETS INAUGURATED AND
THEY HAVE UNDERHANDED MOVE WITH
THE UNION, THEY SAID YOU KNOW,
WE NEED VACCINES IF WE ARE GOING
TO OPEN UP AND AS THEY DID SO,
THEY STILL DID NOT OPEN UP AND
IT WAS NOT UNTIL THE VERY END OF
SPRING SEMESTER THAT ALMOST ALL
THE BLUE STATE SCHOOL DISTRICTS
BEGAN OPENING UP.
SO HE CAN'T SAY THAT.
IT'S LIKE, YOU ARE RIGHT.
IT IS TOTALLY BACKWARDS.
>> I WAS GOING TO BRING UP GLENN
AS A WARNING TO DEMOCRATS, BUT
YOU ALMOST HAD UPSETS AS WELL
AND WHEN YOU DID LOOK AT THE
EXIT POLLS, EVERYTHING IN
DIFFERENT THINGS THAT WERE
BOTHERING THEM THE MOST.
>> I REMEMBER WHEN PUBLIC
EDUCATION WAS A PART OF THIS,
WORKING WITH THE MOST EFFECTIVE
LIBERAL SENATOR, TEDDY KENNEDY,
PASSING THE NO CHILD LEFT BEHIND
ACT.
I WAS IN CONGRESS AT THE TIME.
IT WAS ONE OF THOSE MOMENTS
WHERE IN SOME WAYS YOU ARE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WAYS TO
HELP THESE KIDS, TRYING TO DRAG
DOWN STANDARDS AND STANDINGS
AROUND THE WORLD, THE URBAN
AREAS WHERE YOU HAVE A HEAVIER
CONCENTRATION OF KIDS AND THAT
IS A PROBLEM.
WE HAVE NOW GOTTEN AWAY FROM THE
BIPARTISANSHIP, BUT AS THE ONE,
MAYBE SHE CAN JUST WAVE A WAND,
WHICH I DON'T BELIEVE THAT SHE
CAN.
AND YOU KNOW, DONALD TRUMP, WHEN
HE WAS IN OFFICE THEY TALKED
ABOUT I DIDN'T WANT TO TELL THE
COUNTRY THIS THING WAS SO BAD
BECAUSE I DIDN'T WANT TO BRING
THE ECONOMY TO A HALT.
I SENSE WHERE HE IS COMING FROM.
I GET A SENSE OF WHERE THESE AND
OTHERS WERE COMING FROM AS THEY
WANTED TO GO TO REMOTE SCHOOLING
BECAUSE THEY WERE KIDS LIVING
HIS PARENTS AND GRANDPARENTS,
THOSE THAT HAVE MORBIDITIES AND
PRE-EXISTING CONDITIONS THE KIDS
BROUGHT THE VIRUS HOME.
SO GIVING THEM THE BENEFIT OF
THE DOUBT.
I HOPE THAT WE HAVE LEARNED A
LOT ABOUT WHAT WE DID RIGHT AND
WRONG.
AND I THINK THE TWO DIFFERENT
TAKEAWAYS IS NOT EVERYBODY'S
GOING TO GO TO COLLEGE.
WE HAVE THIS DEBATE, THIS THING
I DIDN'T AGREE WITH, WE WERE ON
THE SAME PAGE ABOUT, STUDENT
LOAN FORGIVENESS, PREPARING KIDS
AND OTHERS WHERE THEY CAN BE
TRAINED TO DO THE THINGS THAT
THE COUNTRY CAN HELP WITH.
ALSO SOME WILL FACE CHALLENGES
BECAUSE WE NEED THOSE THAT CAN
BRING SERVICES INTO THE SCHOOLS
THAT FRANKLY MY TWO KIDS WHO ARE
SO BLESSED, THEY ARE AND WERE
MOSTLY BLESSED, THEY HAD THIS
APPARATUS INFRASTRUCTURE AND I
HOPE THAT WE GET TO THIS AS WELL
AS WE GET TO THE SERIOUS THINGS
THAT THE KIDS ARE FACING.
>> I THINK ALSO IT'S A SCHOOL OF
CHOICE.
AND ALSO 50,000 STUDENTS DIDN'T
EVEN RETURN TO SCHOOL IN LOS
ANGELES.
>> DO YOU HAVE THOUGHTS?
>> I HAVE MANY THOUGHTS.
YOU KNOW, THE JUDGE WAS TALKING
ABOUT IT, THE REFRAMING OF LAW
AND ORDER AND EDUCATION.
>> OH, WOW.
>> WE HAVE A CONTRAST HERE
BETWEEN AN IMAGINARY WAR AND A
REAL WAR.
WE ARE CREATING ON ONE SIDE THE
PSYCHOLOGICAL CONFLICT AND YET
WE GO OUTSIDE, EVERYBODY IS
HAPPY AND FINE.
MEANWHILE THERE IS A REAL BATTLE
GOING ON.
THE BATTLE INVOLVES KIDS.
WHEN YOU HAVE LOCKDOWNS, DRAG
SHOWS, ALL OF A SUDDEN THEY'RE
JUST SHOWING UP EVERYWHERE, WE
HAVE THE PRONOUN POLICE,
SUDDENLY LECTURING ON RACE, WE
ARE NO LONGER HAVING AN EMPHASIS
ON READING AND WRITING BUT ON
THE RACISM OF THE SCHOOL NAMES.
SO THERE IS AN ACTUAL REAL
PRACTICAL FACT-BASED CONFLICT
GOING ON HERE, WHICH IS AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THE REPUBLICANS
TO RECLAIM THEIR RIGHT AS THE
PARENTS PARTY.
SAYING WE ARE NOT GOING TO CALL
YOU DOMESTIC TERRORISTS.
WE ARE NOT GOING TO CHAMPION
GENDER CONFUSION OR CALL KIDS
IRREVOCABLY RACIST.
TAKE A PAGE OUT OF THE HANDBOOK
OF FEAR BY JOE BIDEN.
SCARE PARENTS WITH FACTS.
THIS IS GOING TO BE VERY MUCH A
BROAD STATEMENT.
I REMEMBER WATCHING THE PROTESTS
AFTER DONALD TRUMP ONE AND I SAW
IT AND IT WAS A LOT OF SINGLE
WOMEN, NOT A LOT OF MEN.
AND THE MEN WERE NOT EXQUISITE
SPECIMENS.
I SAW A LOT OF YOUNG AND ANGRY
FEMALES AND THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
HAS BECOME THE PARTY OF YOUNG
AND ANGRY AND SINGLE WOMEN AND A
PLACING ABORTION BEFORE BABIES.
ABORTION ON DEMAND.
THAT IS NOT A PARTY FOR FAMILY.
THAT IS A PSYCHOSIS.
IF YOU THINK YOU CAN ABORT A
CHILD UP TO THE DAY OF BIRTH,
THAT IS INSANE.
SO I THINK THE REPUBLICAN PARTY
SHOULD FOCUS THIS, IT IS RIGHT
THERE, IT'S BEING A BATTLE, AND
DO IT.
RECLAIM, DON'T GET FRAMED.
>> INSANE